hey this is presh talwalker find all
real solutions to the equation the
square of the absolute value of x plus
four multiplied by the absolute value of
x minus 5 is equal to zero
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
recall the definition of the absolute
value of x it is equal to x if x is
greater than or equal to zero and it is
equal to negative x if x is less than
zero
here's a graph of this piecewise defined
function y is equal to the absolute
value of x
if x is greater than or equal to zero we
have the graph of y is equal to X and if
x is less than zero we have the graph of
y is equal to Negative X so we have this
v-shaped graph
to solve this problem we'll consider
each case separately
first we'll consider if x is greater
than or equal to zero
in that case the absolute value of x is
equal to X so we can drop the absolute
value signs and we get the equation x
squared plus 4X minus 5 is equal to zero
we can solve this quadratic equation by
factoring
we get x minus 1 multiplied by X plus 5
is equal to zero this gives the two
solutions X is equal to one and X is
equal to negative five
but in this case we've assumed that X
was greater than or equal to zero so we
need to eliminate the extraneous
solution X is equal to negative five
only X is equal to one is a solution in
this case
we'll move this solution to the side and
we'll consider the other case that X is
less than zero in that case the absolute
value of x is equal to Negative X so we
can substitute in we get the square of
negative X plus four multiplied by
negative x minus five is equal to zero
we simplify to get the quadratic
equation x squared minus 4X minus 5 is
equal to 0.
we solve by factoring to get X Plus 1
multiplied by x minus 5 is equal to zero
and this gives X is equal to negative 1
and X is equal to 5. but in this case we
assume that X was less than zero so we
eliminate the extraneous solution X is
equal to 5. so that's it
this equation has two solutions X is
equal to one or X is equal to negative
one and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time